[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren bei der rede von herrn
merz habe ich gedacht die überschrift
lautet sagt einer dessen
bundestagsfraktion und bundesregierung
16 jahre verantwortung getragen hat und
uns allen im parlament und der
gesellschaft einen
riesenberg nicht erledigte aufgaben
hinterlassen hat meine damen und herren
märz ich weiß ich wo er gerade ist
vielleicht noch im plenum oder nach
getaner rede schon weg aber
ein bisschen weniger männer eitelkeit
ein bisschen mehr selbstreflexion und
vor allen dingen meine damen und herren
ein bisschen mehr
gemeinsame verantwortung angesichts
dieser wirklich krisenhaften zeit wäre
notwendig und wichtig und angemessen
der erdapfel
kollegen seit fast 100 tagen trug putin
zur angriffskrieg in der ukraine
es kann keine aussprache geben um ohne
diesem thema eine große relevanz eine
große aufmerksamkeit zu widmen denn die
lage ist dramatisch morde an
ukrainischen zivilistinnen
vergewaltigung vertreibung massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch die
russische seite sind kriegsalltag
geworden und die große sorge treibt
wahrscheinlich nicht nur mich sondern
uns alle um es gibt irgendwie eine
gewisse gewöhnung an das an dass sich
niemand gewinnen darf nämlich diese
grausamkeit dieses krieges
und dennoch hat putin
obwohl er die offensive in den letzten
tagen deutlich erhöht hat seine
kriegsziele nicht erreicht und das liegt
an der ukraine an dem an der art wie die
ukraine durchhält wie sie kämpft die
zeit läuft gegen putin mit jedem
weiteren tag die menschen in der ukraine
kämpfen und verteidigen ihr land ihre
demokratie ihre freiheit und russland
muss diesen krieg sofort stoppen und
alle kampfhandlungen einstellen dass es
eine wichtige forderung europas aller
der weltgemeinschaft auch nach fast 100
tagen krieg meine damen und herren juli
führt mich den krieg gegen die ukraine
sondern auch gegen unsere gemeinsamen
europäischen und internationalen werte
menschenrechte demokratie freiheit
selbstbestimmung dafür kämpft die
ukraine und wir werden nicht akzeptieren
dass putin die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört mit dem recht
des stärkeren grenzen zu verschieben mit
hoher die welt in geiselhaft zu nehmen
oder das rad der geschichte zurückdrehen
zu wollen und deshalb meine damen und
herren darf putin diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen mir ist wichtig an dieser
stelle noch einmal deutlich zu sagen wir
stehen an der seite der ukraine ja wir
machen uns die daraus folgenden
entscheidungen nicht leicht wir nehmen
die sorgen und nöte und ängste vor einer
ausweitung des krieges sehr ernst auch
wir hadern manchmal auch wir wägen ab
und ja vielleicht könnten manche
entscheidungen auch schneller getroffen
werden
aber wir stehen an der seite der ukraine
und sagen ja zum recht auf
selbstverteidigung und zu
waffenlieferungen zu schweren
waffenlieferung zu denen wir ja gesagt
haben sie gebraucht werden dringend
gebraucht werden und die zugesagt sind
und auf den weg gebracht werden meine
damen und herren wir sagen ja zu
weiteren
aktion bis zum ende fossiler energien
aus russland es ist wichtig dass der
beschluss zum öl embargo endlich kommt
er hat lange gedauert aber jetzt ist er
da die rolle ungarns ist unrühmlich das
wissen wir alle aber wir werden die
ukraine jetzt weiter unterstützen beim
wiederaufbau und bei ihren weg in die
europäische gemeinschaft das ist klar
und auch dieses signal ist eindeutig von
uns hier im parlament ausgegangen und
auch hier
kommen wir jetzt zu der frage deutsche
tragen besondere verantwortung für
frieden in europa und hier herr merz ich
meine es darf doch nicht ihr ernst sein
ein soli für die bundeswehr meine damen
und herren 16 jahre
regierungsverantwortung die gott sei
dank vorbei sind ein soli für die
bundeswehr nachdem an die bundeswehr so
abgewirtschaftet hat mit allen
entscheidungen allen
verteidigungsministern der cdu/csu in
den letzten 16 jahren ich hätte mir mehr
verantwortung von ihnen gewünscht dass
es klar und eindeutig wie deutsche
tragen eine besondere verantwortung für
frieden in europa unsere nachbarn und
verbündeten schauen auf uns erwarten
klarheit entschlossenheit und
gemeinsames handeln und auch deshalb ist
es wichtig dass dieser für uns nicht
einfacher kompromiss zum sondervermögen
jetzt gelungen ist und ausgehandelt ist
ein scheitern wäre keine option gewesen
meine damen und herren und das wissen
alle auch wenn ich als grüne
bundestagsfraktion ganz klar gesagt habe
die vorliegende fassung des kabinetts
wäre die bessere grundlage gewesen aber
es war klar wir brauchen eine
zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag und
deshalb ist es wichtig und richtig dass
es hier zu einem ergebnis gekommen ist
ich nehme zur kenntnis dass leute wie
manfred weber weiter sind als ihre ganze
fraktion und allen voran als ihr
vorsitzender der trend jetzt darauf was
wir eigentlich verankern wollten die
europäische verteidigung und die cyber
abwehr und das nicht einfach nur benannt
ist sondern durch geld hinterlegt das
schild manchen jetzt sehr spät ein wir
grüne fordern seit monaten eine cyber
sicherheitsstrategie mehr geld für den
zivilschutz an uns wird es nicht
scheitern das ist dringend notwendig in
dieser erweiterten sicherheitsbegriff
was die bündnisfähigkeit angeht ist
dringend notwendig sie sind weit weit
hinter der aktuellen debatte in
deutschland und in europa mein gedanken
herum
einige unterstreicht dass die notlage
eine einigung zum sondervermögen
außerhalb der schuldenbremse dann doch
wirklich machen bitte wir haben gerade
gehört was herr merz zu der frage
schuldenbremse gesagt hat wir haben auch
gehört was er zu der frage
sondervermögen gesagt hat schlüssig ist
das alles nicht meine damen und herren
war jetzt sind wir in der lage ein
sondervermögen aufzubauen für die
bundeswehr geht der etf also in der
energie- und klimafonds mit den 60
milliarden wird beim
bundesverfassungsgericht beklagt
gleichzeitig gleichzeitig lässt man ihn
aber stehen und nimmt ihn verdeckung
sämtlicher projekte der union so
funktioniert haushaltsberatung antrag
cdu/csu meine damen und herren aber wir
stehen vor ganz andere herausforderung
und jetzt der union zu beschäftigen auf
dem weiteren weg werden wir zusammen
hier im haus hier in unserem land
darüber diskutieren müssen wir unserer
verantwortung deshalb gerecht werden bei
der wahrung von frieden und sicherheit
beim schutz der menschenrechte bei der
globalen entwicklung beim globalen
klimaschutz und ich bin dankbar dass
hier einer lehre berbalk erste wegmarken
gesetzt der nationalen
sicherheitsstrategie ich bin auch
dankbar dass robert habe die letzten
tagen klar gesagt hat dass
investitionsgarantien
verweigert werden nachdem deutlich wurde
welche gravierenden
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china an
den abo-gebühren
begangen werden
ist deutlich geworden es ist an der zeit
klare haltung klaren kompass und
entschlossenes handeln zu zeigen hier
und jetzt und das tun wir in dieser
woche und unterstreichen das nicht nur
durch die beiden entlastungspaket nicht
nur durch die sehr schwierige debatte
zum sondervermögen sondern auch durch
die entlastungs paket und den haushalt
die wir jetzt auf den weg bringen
gemeinsam als am 4 meine damen viele
menschen im land spüren dass die
groß sind und das ist eine gemeinsame
verantwortung bräuchte mehr gemeinsame
verantwortung bräuchte diese krisen zu
bewältigen
jeder in seinem lebensalltag spürt es an
der kasse im supermarkt oder bei der
nebenkostenabrechnung und in dem kontext
da olaf scholz die konzertierte aktion
angesprochen hat was ist das angesichts
der lage für ein signal wenn ein großer
wohnungsbaukonzern heute ankündigt die
mieten zu erhöhen ist dass das signal
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft nein das
ist es nicht meine damen und herren wir
haben zwei große entlastungs paket auf
den weg gebracht 1 ampelkoalition viele
maßnahmen wie etwa das nur ein euro
ticket greifen ab heute 7 millionen
verkaufte tickets meine damen und herren
sie sehen die menschen wollen dass es
angebote gibt dem öffentlichen
personennahverkehr dass sie bezahlbar
sind dann werden sie auch genutzt das
ist eine riesenchance für uns hier auf
um zu steuern was dringend notwendig ist
seit jahren wir helfen mit den
entlastungs paketen gezielt vor armut
betroffenen kindern mit einem sofort
zuschlag von 20 euro erwachsene in der
grundsicherung mit einer einmalzahlung
von 200 euro
jedes kind in familien mit 100 euro das
wird ein einmaliger heizkostenzuschuss
in höhe von 270 euro ausgezahlt und in
der breite entlasten wir mit der
anhebung des grundfreibetrags der
energiepreis pauschale oder dem neuen
euro ticket allein diesem jahr sind das
entlastung für bürgerinnen und bürger
von weit über 30 milliarden euro meine
damen und herren und das ist ein
wichtiges signal in krisenzeiten an die
bürgerinnen und bürger und ich bin froh
dass wir das als ampel gemeinsam auf den
weg bringen eine dauerkolonie
guten angriffs
klimakrise und die notwendige soziale
und ökologische transformation
wir haben verantwortung in dieser krise
übernommen und tun unser möglichstes
und das ist mit aller ernsthaftigkeit zu
tun wir wissen aber auch dass wir an
vielen anderen stellen dranbleiben
müssen dass wir da liefern müssen es ist
eine vielzahl der herausforderung die
zum handeln drin und es ist auch der
berg den uns die union in 16 jahren
nicht erledigte aufgaben hinterlassen
hat der uns jetzt bringt meine damen und
herren die unmittelbar entlastung sind
das eine die ampel drin nötige
strukturelle veränderungen auf den weg
die abschaffung der eeg umlage oder eben
die einführung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns
alles sehr wichtige sozialpolitische
maßnahmen um die notwendige
transformation zu begleiten und das ist
ein wichtiges signal an bürgerinnen und
bürger und weitere strukturelle
entlastung reformen liegen vor uns jedes
fünfte kind lebt in armut die
kindergrundsicherung muss eingeführt
werden wir haben riesenlücke
sowohl in der frage der zukunft der
rentenversicherung als auch der
gesundheitsversorgung als auch der
pflegeversicherung übernommen unter
kommen sie und fordert diese regierung
aus in der rente was zu tun war sie hat
nicht die letzten 16 jahre meine damen
und herren
sind wo er ist ja so schwer ziemlich
weist aber strukturreformen sind
notwendig und die lücke in der gkv von
20 milliarden euro die hatten sie vor
ort sagt und nicht wir und hielt da und
damit müssen wir uns bedanken und da
erwarte ich von ihnen als sie sagten
bringt sie ihm ein paar vorschläge zur
rente wo leben sie den herrn ihr habt
sie waren sich zehn jahre taten
starbucks ihre aufgabe
und die sich auf mich durch ein klar
ja dafür ist auch ihre aufgabe weil wenn
sie verantwortung tragen
in dieser situation in dieser krise dank
ist es ihre aufgabe diese
krisenbewältigung mitzutragen diese
erwartungen hat mich an sie als
demokratische fraktion und meine damen
und herren
hat einen notwendigen strukturreformen
wirklich vor uns liegt in fragen der
ökologischen transformation in fragen
der sozialen transformation ist nicht
durch ein halbes jahr regierung mal
gerade zu regeln und deshalb habe ich
auch gerade herr merz an ihre
verantwortung appelliert ich meine das
ganz ernst ganz große gesellschaftliche
aufgaben da sollten auch sie
verantwortung tragen denn wir sind zum
teil in dem schlamassel weil sie ihn
nicht bewältigt haben weil sie
weggeguckt haben und das geht zum
beispiel gerade die bekämpfung der
klimakrise an wo waren sie denn die
letzten 16 jahre wir haben es alle
gewusst dass ein umsteuern dringend
notwendig gewesen wäre der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien wurde blockiert
die energie effizienz nicht
vorangebracht
energieeinsparung nicht nein sie haben
uns in diese zementierte abhängigkeit
der fossilien da haben sie uns
eingebracht die vielen entscheidung und
12 liegt in fünf viele große baustellen
gerade vor uns wir können doch nicht
darüber hinweg sehen was sie in ihren in
pakistan die hitzerekorde die durch die
wetter- extreme selbst bei uns wir haben
dramatische folgen und wir haben vor
allen dingen den auftrag des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes ganz klar als
aufgabe für das parlament uns hier
gesetzt bekommen auch sie die bekämpfung
der klimakrise die frage der künftigen
generationen und ihrer freiheit ist bei
allen künftigen entscheidungen zu wahren
und zu beachten das ist unser auftrag
und den haben sie 60 jahren verweigert
also lassen sie heute meiden backen
nicht so auf soll dann tut sie mit das
wäre angesagt und meine damen und herren
wenn ich an diese ganzen wirklich
relevanten und großen veränderungen
denke dann ist doch klar dass das nicht
durch ein paar einsparungen hier oder da
oder zwei bekenntnisse zur
schuldenbremse zu regeln ist wir sind in
einer notlage und wir werden überlegen
müssen wie wir aus dieser notlage mit
zukunftsinvestitionen rauskommen das ist
die zentrale frage meine damen und
herren
das gerät ist hier und heute und führt
sie zu mir und wir erwarten im bereich
der internationalen verpflichtungen
keine akzente gesetzt in diesem haushalt
aber bei einem 1 zu 1 prinzip sind wir
noch nicht und deshalb geht es auch um
die globale verantwortung für uns alle
darüber wird weiter zu diskutieren sein
ich halte es für dringend geboten das
mit klaren kompass klarer haltung und
entschlossenem handeln für die zukunft
in den nächsten monaten es weitergeht
und wir klare aufgaben vor uns liegen
die zu tun sind machen sie mit
entscheiden sie sich dafür auch
verantwortung zu übernehmen sie müssen
sie eigentlich spüren aus den letzten 16
jahren untätigkeit
[Applaus]